相変わらずていますよね東京でございますそしてなんとここ東京でも夜帆を不正街
六本木でございました肺年齢も
素問だけ
はいいうわけで今日のメインチャンネル動画別に僕がの講義をぶらつく動画ではあり
ませんでなぜ僕が今ここでどうぞとっているかといいますと派の皆さんに
皆さんにお話じゃなければいけないことがありますちょうど2年前だと思うんですけど
も
2年前に僕があの東京でお部屋を借りましたっていう友達と思うんですけども
ついに
追い出されました
というわけでもないんですけど決して追い出されたわけでもないんですけどほぼ次節今
東京の桜家がなくなってしまいました
あいつだけどちょっと驚きかもしれないんですけども今東京に僕の居場所はありません
ゼロですずっと攻めたを違ったんですけどもなんでショップがダメになったかっていう
とまあいろんな映画なび
ましぇいぷれいうと2年契約だったので2年間経って出て行くことになりましたという
だけです
ハッピーそんなオーボエを出してないし追い出されるようなことを全くしてないんです
か大丈夫ですよ
英霊がてぃぶなことではないんですけどもたまにしか来ない陶業のためにそんなた歌謡
金出してるのこと馬鹿らしくなったんで雑感値段を抑えつつ数なんで僕が東京
に来るかっていうのをふーむの事務所に行くことがほぼハツリー近くなんで部の近くと
いうこと
この2点を踏まえたうえで何とかなんとですね新しい
東京のうち焼き生まれました明日いうビスなんですけどごめんなさいも一刻も早く新党
に来た来てみんなが泊まってるホテルを抜き出してきてしまいました外してというわけ
で早速新しい大津に向かってみましょう
自分の家がはかなぁ
待っても結構ある移設へモーヤーようなでも結構使い気がすんだよなぁ持ったれてみ
ましょう
遠く年遠い世六本木得ない
オレンジないようでちょっと本当にはなんだよ入ったことないからそうだろうけど
あっおっ立って違いなプレーもこれだっ
女だあああああ
上田たむアイプチ等です
それが僕の新しい緩い
ん
[音楽]
はい
発信所の香りこれが診療で大理石だいだい酢てきたのかな
今回ちょっとキッチンもあるとそしてこれが肇社長の
新居わー
おしゃれ塩蔵シャレっ
相次いでコブラー文里の東京の新居運営がこれええというですねちょっと多少が空が
入ってるんですよご覧くださいチャンネル別途 r ってね編集用付もある光線と動い
てる
実はですね母ちゃんが全部準備してくれました
柘植人物宣伝
に動いてるか書いてるバーンな僕にも分かりやすい本当にすぎあり家庭
全部吐いちゃう
全部書いたら俺にどんな現場だと思われてるんや
ありがたいことですなるほどなるほどはいはいという感じですね
全部書いてありますどっこいしょとははいというわけで東京の心境でございます i
つーわけでちょっと引越した理由が色々あるんですけども混ぜ今でいただきましょう
前住んでいた東京の家
浅めでございました麻布十番でございますねこう麻布
東京の麻布ってどんなイメージがあるかっていうとこうなんかちょっと落ち着いてん
じゃありません
比較的にあの街にイベントに若い人はいなかったんですよなんで僕は山の街結構歩いて
いても全然大丈夫だったんねやっぱ youtube 見てる人が若い人多いから
もう麻布にせむのケッ
1にあったなぁと思ってたんですけどまぁなんで東京に毎日得るわけでもないので
麻布十番のマンション借りてて結構たかったんですよちなみに言いましょう
最上階だったんですよ go 2戦ででちょっとやっぱりたまに来るためだけに
毎月8日に春之助馬鹿らしくなってきちゃってまあそれであればちょっとで防災れば
いいかなと思って
とやすくしたり部屋の音なんかたくさんいらないなと思って部屋をちょっと小さくし
たり色々とコンパクトにまとめさせていただきました
ちなみにうまでの道のりは
多分歩けない音で遠かったです
あいうえで今後実際あの前住んでたザムの良い方法はありませぬが離婚がこちらの部屋
で東京に行くとけどワードが来ると思うのでこれをございます
電源後何度かないんだけど母ちゃんがいろいろ準備してくれたんでもカーテンとか置い
てあった
第2つ有りますちょっとでも見て3日
全部わかりますねただうちの母さんの指ではここで多分これだけ編集するのは何て読な
んでしょうねこうやってこういう意味でもいいです
結構小さめなんですけどラン別に何かたまにくれないんだからいいんだなと思いまして
もちろん何か前にしてるんだからもっとガーフであったしてもうシャンディア6ブー
ルってもいいと思ったんですけど金がもったいないということでそんなことには使える
廃砦信者なんですけども東京に遅物でくるときたまに止まるくらいではここで動画を
撮る時もあると思うんであると皆様今後ともよろしくお願い致します始め
アミューズメントタイプ東京
めっちゃ復帰見て自分の足で運んだりしてめっちゃたつかめた結果ここになったので
あの
いい感じになってると思うので東京に来たときは僕はこの夢止まりますよと
ねえよっ
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
あっはぁ